be looking at
restrictions on indoor mixing this
christmas can families be reassured that
that is not going to happen now well as
the prime minister set out yesterday we
keep these issues under close review
obviously there's considerable
uncertainty within the omicron data were
concerned about the increasing growth in
cases particularly in london but there
is a considerable time lag between those
catching the the infection and
presenting as cases at hospital and of
course that needs to look in the round
alongside the booster campaign the
increase in treatments
the changes in behavior as a consequence
of plan b
which will also have an impact on those
hospital admissions so that's why we're
looking so closely at the hospital data
particularly around london where omicron
is more prevalent
and we're balancing that against the
wider economic consequences of any
further restrictions which also carry
health risks for reasons tomorrow you've
often highlighted on the program in
terms of the mental health consequences
for example as well as those wider
economic consequences of course hospital
data is hugely important are you
expecting any more data this week is
there a critical point coming up where
you think that decision will need to be
made well we're getting data all the
time on an hour by hour day by day basis
both internationally we're looking at
data although there are issues around
the comparability of that people often
will say for example look at the south
african data we need to be conscious
that the age profile is different it's
summer there as opposed to winter here
their health care system is different so
we're looking internationally at data
whether in south africa whether in
denmark or elsewhere we're looking
regionally at the different profiles for
example london uh where over 88 percent
of cases um uh presenting as emissions
are macron compared to 43 44 in the
north east so we're looking at regional
data we're also looking for example at
the ons data where they have a gold
standard in terms of the survey they
conduct so we're looking at a range of
factors and of course that needs to be
balanced alongside the economic
consequences of further restrictions
which are very severe
and have a real impact on the
livelihoods and the businesses of many
of your viewers obviously the
hospitality industry and others the
entertainment industry as well having a
really tough time already as people
choose to stay at home are we going to
get an announcement from the chancellor
today and what's more support might be
made available well firstly of course
there is some existing support so that
we should be conscious of for example on
business rates on vat
so there is existing support as part of
the wider package of measures that the
treasury has provided throughout
the cavity pandemic but of course you're
quite right as consequence of plan b we
have seen behavior change so we
therefore need to distinguish between
what are some of the the shorter term
impacts versus some of the longer term
us the chancellor has been discussing
that with business leaders he was
discussing he was on a series of calls
with business leaders uh yesterday
evening henny will have more to say
about that later today my last question
mr barkley
is patrick valance has always said the
chief scientific officer has always said
with restrictions you need to go earlier
than you want broader than you want
harder than you want otherwise if you
wait till the hospitals fill up it can
be too late are you alive to that
concern is that something that ministers
you feel your colleagues are aware of
when they're resisting restrictions well
you're absolutely right that
time has a consequence and sir patrick
has
made that point quite rightly in terms
of the path of the pandemic but at the
same time decisions have an economic
consequence in terms of further
restrictions the impact on businesses
you your previous question was about the
impact on the hospitality industry so
that's exactly the sort of thing we need
to weigh up but we also need to look at
that in the round in terms of the new
treatments the anti-rivals that are now
available that weren't previously the
booster campaign uh particularly with
those most at risk of hospital
admissions those older age groups are
those most likely to have been boosted
and also the impact of plan b itself so
so these are the issues so patrick's
right that uh time has uh a cost
but at the same time
we need to look at the the consequence
of decisions in terms of economic
measures and that's exactly what cabinet
discussed yesterday